what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content here on my
channel then make sure you hit the like
button and make sure you hit subscribe
so you can't decide what direction the
content on my channel goes in in the
foreseeable future
okay so the x-men are like the most
confusing thing ever
right like people will sit down and
they're like okay x-men yeah I've heard
the house of him now let's move on to my
god because they feel like astonishing
x-men uncanny x-men x-men vol you to
x-men legacy Wolverine x-23 Dark
Avengers dark x-men they just feel like
a ton of stories and they're like I
don't even know where to begin like I
don't even know probably know how to
start
so here's we're going to do for the next
two weeks we're going to test the waters
now we're doing this for two weeks for
two reasons one because over the course
of the next few weeks we'll cover the
entirety of Joss Whedon's run of
astonishing x-men as well as a couple
other titles I'm not sure yet but I'm
thinking about doing like Phoenix in
song Phoenix war song um but we're going
to cover Joss Whedon's astonishing x-men
and then once we're done we're going to
figure out what we're going to do but uh
if people care if people are interested
then what you guys what we're going to
do is we're going to cover the
chronology of the extra because what you
guys don't know is I've created a
spreadsheet that literally goes to the
entire chronology of the x-men covering
everything in a perfectly understandable
way like I can make a playlist it would
be like 70 videos long and by the time
that playlist is done we will have
covered everything between house of them
and all new x-men and you will have no
confusion whatsoever you will be like so
this is everything that happens in the
x-men universe and so Joss Whedon's
astonishing x-men is the only thing
that's like really confusing at all it's
I'm really not confusing it's really
more of like placement like where does
it go it's kind of one of those weird
things because the idea is effectively
hinted at that it takes place after the
events of house event but can also take
place before the events of house of M
because Xavier is not in the picture
during the events before the house of
them in the days leading up to the house
is an event Xavier had basically kind of
vacated his role as leader of the x-men
because he was in Genosha and he was
working alongside magneto to try to deal
with the insanity of the Scarlet Witch
after the events of Avengers
disassembled but after the events of
house of M Xavier was just gone he had
just vanished
now x-men deadly Genesis marked the
return of Charles Xavier after the
events of house of M but regardless of
how this fits in we know Xavier is not
here so this story really kind of sets
the stage in a lot of ways for the idea
of Emma Frost and Cyclops taking over
the x-men team now again this also comes
out of new x-men but the only thing we
really need to worry about is the idea
that Jean Grae basically died at the end
of that story really towards the end of
that story that's really about it now in
terms of why it is that Emma and Cyclops
are running the show right now it's
simply because of the fact that during
the story at the end of a new x-men
called here comes tomorrow
it basically portrayed a future where
Cyclops had left the idea of running the
x-men following the death of Jean Grey
he said okay look the professor actually
isn't going to run the x-men I'm not
going to run him either and he basically
just walked away from the whole thing
this led to a very dystopian future
where beasts basically just kind of went
insane and became a villain what the
story did is that the end of here comes
tomorrow Jean grade is kind of reached
back into the past and sort of nudged
Cyclops in the direction of leading the
x-men which leads us to where we are
right now because the what just does is
it basically opens up with Emma Frost
and you know really Cyclops and then
kind of declaring the idea that they're
going to be running the school what
direction the school goes and it's
really kind of like the opening session
for a lot of new students and what ends
up happening here is in the middle of
their whole discussion the room is
attacked by Seminoles well of course
this is basically revealed to be the
Danger Room this is something just a
session that Emma Frost had created to
instill in the fact to a lot of students
that they will never be accepted by
humanity the mutants will always be
shunned they'll always be looked down on
now this is one of the coolest parts of
the x-men landscape it had always been
that way but this is not the crux of the
entirety of the x-men run in some ways
it is but the entire run really the
entire kind of relaunch or reworking of
the x-men and the post house of M
landscape was to not only focus on the
idea to the x-men are constantly
oppressed but to also expand on the
story of the x-men the legacy of the
x-men the actions of the team all these
different changes in all these different
scenarios that were unfolding the return
of Vulcan that's omegat level mutant who
was the third summer's brother and
region losing his mind you know started
the whole age of X scenario that's what
all that was about and so because of
this this also follows again the death
of Jean Grey and so at this point
there's still some measure of a mourning
phase or you would expect there to be
but if fine actually breaks out between
Cyclops and wove range is because
Wolverine looks at Cyclops who's
basically betting Emma Frost and it's
just kind of like well I guess this is
part of that mourning phase you know
where your wife dies it was part of that
phase where you're trying to get over
her death by sleeping around with other
people so again it's kind of a
interesting scenario but what this does
and the reason why this story is called
gifted is because a woman named dr. rau
basically appears to this meeting that's
been called this kind of celebration of
Victorian architecture
those lines and basically says we found
a cure for the x-gene we found a way to
basically cure all mutants in existence
now of course this draws the attention
of the x-men proper who basically end up
finding out that there was a young girl
named tilt and what we found out about
her character is that she had the mutant
power to make her dreams or make her
nightmares physical she could literally
in turn her nightmares in the physical
constructs which resulted in the death
of both of her parents and a cop who it
has you know been called to the house by
her parents in a state of panic but this
also introduces a guy by the name of
Ford now with this whole scenario with
Ord it's really just kind of him you
know attacking the location and so on
and the x-men responding accordingly now
the funny thing about this is the x-men
are easily overpowered by orden that's
one of the crazy things is because he's
basically able to counter each and every
one of their maneuvers you know when it
comes to Emma Frost turning into her
diamond form her secondary mutation or
is able to counter this by simply
overpowering her physically with someone
able to overpower her it also puts him
across in a pretty dangerous spot
because if he shatters her in her
diamond form she'll die and so again
it's really kind of an interesting
scenario now of course or basically kind
of calls it a retreat after kitty prides
dragon runs up on board and shoot some
of fire I mean that's that happened it's
it's there's it's the thing that took
place the fact remains here that the
questioning comes rolling in to the
various mutants you know to the x-men
once they once they basically leave
reporters asking the question are you
guys the one who started it what's going
on with all this you know a lot of
questions that are that are being asked
here but more so than that it's also the
kind of you know strain between Emma
cross and Kitty Pryde because remember
the first time that Emma Frost was
introduced into Marvel Comics by Chris
Claremont she was a bad guy she would
effectively kidnap the x-men I believe
with her hellions and Kitty Pryde was
one of a handful of means they were able
to help when the x-men's escaped and
basically kind of take the day but the
idea is that at the end of the day Kitty
Pryde doesn't trust Emma Frost in any
form or fashion it's really kind of an
interesting scenario with regards to the
two of them going against each other and
so what we end up doing was he actually
picked up with beasts as he travels to
see dr. Ralph and basically reveal that
he himself has a partial interest and
seeing whether or not this cure works
and possibly even using on himself now
that's a cool thing about this because
right off the bat you'll notice this
story is almost directly in line with
x-men 3 which is fine because that movie
sucked and this story's a whole lot
better so fox give the x-men back to
Marv Boyle if you could have made good
movies you would have
by now so anyway when it comes to you
know this whole scenario is kind of
interesting because there's a sort of
line that doesn't get crossed when it
comes to the x-men and Emma Frost on the
whole Emma cross usually doesn't read
the minds of members of the x-men
unless she absolutely has to just
because of the fact that she's trying to
basically get the x-men to trust her as
she's been a part of the team but in
this instance with beast suddenly
showing back up and saying hey look I
got a sample of this cure from dr.
Rausch she gave it to me because I was
bound to find it you know we were bound
to get our hands on it at some point
anyway Emma Frost ends up reading his
mind and fine you know figuring out that
beast motivation lies in the fact that
he is kind of interested in testing out
to see if the Cure works and then
possibly even use it on themselves now
the other half of this is Cyclops
visiting Nick Fury and again that's one
of the coolest things about this is
because with the x-men it's very easy to
forget how close they are with the rest
of the Marvel Universe it's very easy to
forget how intertwined they are with
everything else because people tend to
think of the accident and they think of
those terrible Fox movies except for
like the two good ones that they may
think of the Avengers in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe and the x-men not
being there and they tend to think of
the X n is kind of being off in their
own universe out in no-man's land but
the cool thing about these stories you
know seeing Cyclops
going to visit Nick Fury and saying hey
look what do you know about this guy
what do you know about this mutant cure
you know this guy or what do you how
does all this fit together it makes
sense it actually kind of creates a
cohesiveness now there is a Cyclops
visits Nick Fury is remember Nick Fury
is the director of shield and Nick Fury
knows all I mean he knows and sees off
there's very rarely anything that
happens on earth in Marvel comics that
Nick Fury does not know about because
this guy's seen and done it all but of
course there's not a whole lot of love
lost between Nick Fury and the x-men
just because of the fact that harkening
back to the events of new x-men when
Zorn was first introduced into Marvel
Comics we ended up realizing or ended up
finding out it was magneto masquerading
as a potential new mutant for the
purpose of taking over the x-men and
essentially like destroying New York
launching attacks so on and so forth the
fact that the attack on New York was
moderately successful in the sense of
there were some casualties the city was
kind of twisted inside and out means
that shield always looked at the x-men
with a slanted eye the idea of Cyclops
saying well the x-men don't take in
villains you know the fact that Emma
Frost is a villain they took her in
Cyclops is you know leading the school
along with her the two of them have a
romantic relationship it really kind of
contradicts the nature of the x-men
that's kind of a funny thing is because
on the whole the x-men do the best they
have with what they've got but at the
end of the day in a lot of ways they're
still considered vigilantes by a lot of
different people because of the tactics
that they use to achieve their goals
it's not their intention to be bad guys
it's just occasionally they come off
that way and when you're Nick Fury and
you're the director of shield and you've
got a guy standing in front of your face
saying you need to give me answers and
the guy's preaching about how he's doing
the right thing while at the same time
in a relationship with a criminal it
kind of stretches the limits of
credulity and the limits of trust and so
again it's really kind of a cool
scenario here but at the end of the day
what ends up happening is that his beast
begins going through and looking at
these looking at this sample that the
various samples that were used to attain
the cure he comes to the realization
that it seems like mutant DNA is being
used or has been used to make this cure
and so what we do is we actually pick up
with the x-men traveling over to
Benetech labs which is basically the
place where this cure is coming from now
the other half of this is the reaction
of the mutant community when it was
announced publicly that there was a cure
to mutation thousands of mutants flocked
to this lab in order to get this cure
and you have to think about that I mean
it makes perfect sense I mean just like
the Morlocks on their own I mean the
Morlocks exist in the tunnels of New
York they live underground because their
mutations are so extreme when it comes
to their physical appearance they can't
walk around in the general public they
have mutations that allow them to do a
wide array of different things but they
look starkly different from a normal
person and that's kind of the dichotomy
when it comes to mutant powers the good
guy versus the bad guys the ones who
look fine versus the ones who don't and
so if you had a physical mutation that
made you look different and you could
live presumably unnormal life you could
open you know regular checking accounts
you could walk around without people
looking at you funny you would have to
worry about your rights being restricted
wouldn't you jump on that opportunity
and that's what makes this story so cool
it's because it says if your situation
sucked and somebody came to you and they
gave you a key if the gate keeper said
hey here's the key that'll get you to
this door
wouldn't you take it if on the other
side of that door was possibly a much
better life than the one that you live
that's what's so cool about this that's
why it works so well now of course the
x-men responding you know traveling to
Benetech labs again it's just for the
purpose of going through and kind of
analyzing these samples and so on and so
forth but we also end up finding out
that Ord had actually traveled back to
the x-men mansion for the purpose of
attacking the x-men just because at this
point their investigations have hindered
the possibility of this mutant cure
being successful but the funny thing
about this
we don't know what Ords involvement with
regards to this mutant cure is all we
know is that he's the one perpetuating
this here he's the one that's basically
going forward and saying here's
everything you need with regard to
engineering the cure of the mutant virus
and so what we do is we switch over to
Kitty Pryde and what is possibly the
absolute greatest moment in this first
story and we have her going through you
know these different aspects of Benetech
labs you know going underground and
looking at all the different structures
and so on and she eventually comes
across a massive large room as well as a
handful of guards now once she opens the
safe what she cracks it you know uses
her power to phase through the guards
realize she's there and fire off a shot
this shot bounces off of a metal object
only for us to find out that this is
Colossus now let me tell you some
runners run up when this happened man
when this happened like when when
Colossus was revealed to be alive people
freaked like you could not find this
comic in stores anywhere it was the talk
of the town forum post the whole nine
yards everyone was talking about it
because it was one of the the single
biggest things had YouTube been around
at the time this story was written
YouTube would have exploded like it was
just one of the craziest things to
happen just because of the fact that
Colossus had been dead so it's like 1997
or 99 or something like that Colossus
died injecting himself with the cure for
the legacy virus to save mutant kind
then the idea was that he was gone
forever I mean he was never going to
come back but to have him suddenly
appear here changed everything and
that's what makes us that's what makes
this whole thing so gorgeous and so
beautiful is because he appears and he
just runs he goes directly after those
guys who were shooting at him Kitty
Pryde just automatically I mean he just
runs through her you know she
automatically shields herself from the
bullets you know he runs right through
or her reaction is just like oh my god
and the reason why is because they were
an item they were together they were as
in love as two characters could be when
it came to comic books him sacrificing
his life was crushing for Kitty Pryde
the idea that Marvel toyed with with
this was that when Colossus died it was
almost like will Kitty Pryde ever
recovered will she ever come back from
this and it was one of the craziest
things because now he's here and so
again it was just like this mind-blowing
moment in comics and it's one of my
absolute favorite moments and the
entirety of Joss Whedon's run it's
really one of the biggest things that
he's remembered for is bringing Colossus
back you know was resurrecting Colossus
from the
now this also coincides with the idea of
or you know confronting the confronting
the various members of the the x-men
team and you know dr. rau appearing and
so on and so forth but getting to that
here in a second the explanation that's
offered here when it comes to Colossus
is really kind of weird and this is the
other side of the equation where people
were ecstatic about the idea of Colossus
coming back the explanation on how he
got there was a little less than stellar
what we were basically told is that when
Colossus had sacrificed his life to the
legacy virus he basically and whisked
away by order and essentially just kind
of been resurrected and so the idea was
that he was used as an experiment by
orden ducked around in order to create
this cure for for the for the mutant
gene and then in turn it was given dr.
rau who would disperse it the motivation
behind this isn't really known but it's
really just kind of like this
interjected explanation for how it is
that Colossus ended up coming back which
wasn't the greatest explanation ever but
it served its purpose and they did what
it was supposed to do but with Ord you
know traveling back here this is an
amazing moment because Ord confronts all
the x-men and it's really kind of funny
because we end up having like Kitty
Pryde showing up with Colossus and the
response of like beasts and more rain
and Emma Frost is just like what
everybody's reaction to him coming back
it's just like what no way man no way
Colossus is back and it's so cool to see
because what doesn't happen is Colossus
just kind of like reached out him he
loses his mind and starts going to
attack Ord and it just absolutely filled
with rage before they can get any
further you know Emma Frost will reign
Colossus Kitty Pryde doctor out they're
all met with the arrival of Abigail
brand and Nick Fury and this is when we
find out exactly what it is that's going
on here now the cool thing about this is
that Abigail brand as she's introduced
here is their first introduction into
Marvel Comics this is Joss Whedon
basically creating and introducing the
organization known as sword now sorry I
mean as you can see in here a sword
stands for sentient world observation
and response Department but the funny
thing though the really cool reaction by
Nick Fury is like okay you know like you
guys have questions I have questions my
question is wasn't that guy dad it is
like the laws are supposed to be dead
and again everybody's kind of reacting
to the fact that Colossus is still alive
not only that when the question is asked
how do you guys know it's him the
reaction of beasts is funny because you
name across like I read his mind beasts
is like AI matches the
nay Wolverines like I smell them and
visas like I did that chick so it's just
these funny little moments the you know
they kind of you know bring us back to
ground bring us back to everything when
it comes to come to Colossus returning
but what we end up finding out here is
it again with the sentient world
observation and response department they
are one of a litany of organizations
that exists in Marvel Comics we've got
shield you've got hammer you've got
strike you've got all different kinds of
groups but where shield monitors earth
or you know any kind of threat that
exists out there Hydra or anything along
those lines advanced idea mechanics
various threat you know that the normal
superheroes need to be kept aware of the
sentient world observation and response
department does the exact same thing but
monitors other worlds and so they look
out into the universe they see the Kree
Empire the Shiar Empire you know the
scroll Empire any one of those groups
and if they start making battle
formations in preparation of attacking
the planet Earth the various superheroes
will be notified by Abigail brand she's
basically Billy Azon of the sentient
world observations and response
Department ahead of sort and so what we
end up finding out here is that the
intervention of ORD came with the idea
that he comes from breakworld and the
idea is that somewhere you know where
his people were able to kind of glimpse
into the future they can only see it but
can't change it in about three years
time some mutants somewhere is going to
completely obliterate breakworld and so
really Ord showing up here on earth is
designed for the purpose of keeping that
from happening it's very similar to
Bishop right like Bishop comes from a
timeline is almost identical to the Days
of Future past where someone killed a
million humans in seven seconds we ended
up learning it was Hope Summers the
bishops entire role in the you know
really the stories that were we talking
about later on especially when we get to
like Messiah War and things like that
is the idea that Bishop is trying to
kill Hope Summers so we can prevent his
future from happening that's exactly
what happens here it's just the classic
example of trying to keep his people
from being totally obliterated some
three years in the future now of course
before we could end up getting into all
that you know we basically have all
these mutants these crazy mutants to
break into the facility for the purpose
of you know trying to get the cure and
that kind of thing really just an act of
desperation but in the panic and in the
ensuing chaos or takes off and grabs
till really the girl that's been cured
so far grabs her and whisks you know
wish the two of them away takes off in
his ship just because of the fact that
she's the perfect host for the Cure now
she possesses it in her genes and so
what this would do is it will allow or
the
unity to basically strip her of the cure
and then use it in order to come back
later on down the line or disperse it
among the entirety of earth and some you
know gaseous form or selling along those
lines but of course the greatest moment
in the comedy single greatest moment the
comic comes when Wolverine asked
Colossus he's like hey man are you
feeling you're feeling good you feeling
rested up in classes like yeah I'm ready
like you thinking what I'm thinking in
classes like yeah hey Wolverine says
fastball special for those of you guys
who don't know the fastball special is a
hallmark of the Wolverine Colossus
relationship it is where Colossus just
throws will rain and it's amazing the
fastball special is one of the coolest
things it would be it'd be so cool to
see in like the Marvel Cinematic
Universe you see like infinity war and
like Colossus just throws Wolverine at
Thanos but of course you know Wolverine
getting on board the ship really just
kind of tearing it apart with adamantium
claws leads to or basically being taken
prisoner and that's really about it but
the way the story ends you know with
Kitty Pryde and Colossus kind of
reconciling and catching up on all the
time they've missed it ends with someone
that we can't see someone presumably
issuing orders to Emma Frost or asking
her questions you know saying things
like this changes the equation and the
idea that Kitty Pryde seems to be the
most dangerous and that win whatever it
is it starts this revolution or this
attempt to eliminate all the x-men when
it takes place that Kitty Pryde will be
the first one to be eliminated she'll be
the most difficult to kill because you
can faze yourself this basically seems
like someone somewhere has either seized
control of Emma Frost or Emma Frost is
working with them and she's effectively
a bad guy but with that being said guys
if you are new here to comment explain
make sure you guys have the sub button
to become part of the ROM or if you guys
enjoyed this video make sure you drop a
like let me know if you guys want to see
some more x-men stuff again we're just
trying out Joss Whedon's astonishing
x-men we will run through all 24 issues
which will make about four videos or
something like that and then we'll just
kind of see how things work we'll just
kind of see what goes from there but
anyway guys we're gonna go ahead and
bring this video to an end and I will
catch you all later peace
[Music]
you